PROFESSOR: Any questions about
where we left off-- up to
where we left off?
OK, what I'll do then is give
you a few more examples of the
combinations in 22 to show which
ones we have to retain
as frameworks for
crystallographic point groups
and which ones exist as groups
but which involve rotational
symmetries that are not
permitted to a lattice.
So we've seen a combination of
three orthogonal twofold axes
and then projection that
would look like this.
And the international symbol for
that point group is just a
running list of the different
axes that are present, 222.
The next group in the sequence
would be 3 2 2, where we took
a 120 degree rotation.
We combine that with a twofold
axis perpendicular to it and
the new twofold axis comes out
and reminds you again of
things that are quite clear but
which are easy to forget--
that this angle here is
1/2 of 2 pi over 3.
Don't forget that 1/2.
So the neighboring twofold axis
is 60 degrees away and
then if we allow these axes to
operate on each other, the net
symmetry consistent set of
axes looks like this.
But let us look at a solid
that has this symmetry.
And such a solid would
be a trigonal--
triangular prism.
And again we can use the corners
of this polyhedron as
the reference locations
of our motifs.
So let us put a first motif
here, number 1.
Let's rotate it by 120 degrees
to get a second motif here.
And then let us rotate that
one down by a twofold axis
coming out of one
of the edges.
That will give us number 3 that
is down here or of the
same chirality.
And how do we get from 1 to
3 directly in one shot?
And the answer is about a
twofold axis that comes out of
the face of the prism.
So again the prism that we've
used as our reference is a
prism that looks like this.
We've got one twofold axis
coming out of the face.
The next twofold axis is the
one that is equivalent to a
threefold rotation followed
by a twofold rotation.
Now here we hit a situation in
deciding on the name for the
combination that is analogous
to what we found in
two-dimensional plane
groups for 3mm.
We saw that only one mirror
plane was distinct.
We look at this arrangement
of axes--
this was axis a, alpha,
this was axis b, beta.
But if I repeat one of these
twofold axes by 120 degree
rotations, this one is the
opposite end of this one, this
one is the opposite end of this
one, and this one is the
opposite end of this one.
So there are only three kinds
of-- there are three, twofold
axes and they are related by
the 120 degree rotation.
Another way of saying that is
that if we look at a trigonal
prism, each of the twofold axes
comes out of an edge and
out of the opposite face.
So there they all do the same
thing in this regular prism--
twofold axes extend between
corners of the opposite face.
So there are only--
there's only one kind of twofold
axis present in terms
of being symmetry independent.
So just as we called 3mm, 3m,
and we call this one 3 2
because all the twofold axes
are symmetry equivalent.
The next one that is
crystallographic would be a
combination of a 90 degree
rotation with a pair of
twofold axes that are normal to
it and separated by 1/2 of
pi over 2, the [? throw ?]
of a fourfold axis.
And the symbol for this one
would be a fourfold and now
there are two different
kinds of twofold axes.
And if we look at a regular
square prism, we can again
show that what we've been
demonstrating for these other
prisms is true.
One twofold axis would come
out of the face, the other
twofold axis would come out of
the midpoint of an edge, and
the fourfold axis would
come up here.
And a 90 degree rotation, from
here to here, followed by a
twofold rotation about this
axis, gives us as a net
effect a 1, 2, 3.
And that rotation from 1 to 3
about this twofold axis gives
us the combined mappings.
Notice that the order in which
we do them is unimportant.
For example we could do the
same thing but do two 180
degree rotations about
the twofold axes.
Let's say we start by doing
a rotation about
this twofold axis.
From here down to here.
And then we do a twofold
axis about the--
twofold axis that comes out the
face and that would take
number 2, and rotate
it up to number 3.
And the way we get from 1 to 3
directly is by a rotation of C
pi over 2 about the square
face of the prism.
So do them in any
order you like--
two 180 degree rotations, or a
90 degree rotation, one of the
two full rotations with 90
is the other twofold--
the other type of
twofold axis.
The 90 degree rotation plus the
second type of the twofold
axis is the same as the first.
So the result can be permuted
and turns out to be the same
combination.
The next one that we would hit
if we proceed systematically
is non-crystallographic.
And this would be
a fivefold axis.
And I'm foolhardy to even start
trying to sketch this in
three dimensions.
Nevertheless, nothing ventured,
nothing gained.
Start with a twofold axis out of
one of the edges and rotate
from 1 down to 2.
Follow that by a twofold
rotation about the twofold
axis that comes out
of the face.
And that gives us one number 3
up here, and lo and behold,
the way you get from 1 to 3
directly is by a rotation
through 1/5 of 2 pi.
So this would be the
non-crystallographic point
group, 5- well it's not
going to be 5 2 2.
And that has a whole bunch
of twofold axes separated
by 1/10 of 2 pi.
And just as in 3 2, twofold axes
here all come out of the
face and out of the
opposite edge.
So this would be called 522.
A nice symmetry but not
crystallographic, so we can
promptly forget about.
So what comes out of this is a
family of groups that are all
of the form n 2 2.
The crystallographic ones are
222, 32, 422 which we've
looked at in detail, and one
that I won't draw because
there's so much symmetry
it get's messy.
This is 622.
There is a Schoenflies
notation.
You remember the language that
we encountered for our two
dimensional point groups.
We used m for mirror in the
international notation.
We used C standing for cyclic
group, subscript s standing
for Spiegel in the Schoenflies
notation.
The Schoenflies notation for all
of this family of symmetry
is Dn, and the D stands
for dihedral.
And the reason for that name is
that the difference between
all of these groups, besides the
n-fold axis, is this angle
between adjacent twofolds and
this is a dihedral angle.
I have a set of planes passing
through a common axis; the
angle between those planes is
termed a dihedral angle.
So this is called D for dihedral
and then a subscript
that gives the rank
of the axis.
So Dn generically.
This is D2, this is D3, this
is D4, and this is D6.
Comments or debate?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
--out of this face.
So I got from here down to the
diametrically opposed axis.
And I rotate it about the
adjacent one which comes out
of an edge and--
what did I do here.
Here I did A pi over 2 from 1
to 2, and then I did B pi,
where this is B pi, and they
turned out to be C pi, which
is this one here.
So going from here to here down
to number 3 is the same
as going from 1 to 3 in one
shot about a twofold axis
normal to the face.
And actually I'm courageous
to try to do this in three
dimensions.
We could do it in projection
and then things are used--
this for a point that's up,
and use this for a point
that's down.
And then what we've done is to
go from 1 that's up, to 2
that's up, and then we rotate
it about this twofold axis.
That was 3, that's down.
So when we get into complicated
symmetries where
you just can't do a proper
job drawing them in an
orthographic drawing, we'll do
them in projection and use a
solid dot for something that's
up and an open circle for
something that's down.
Is there any other way we
can combine things?
Well what you would have to do
is use these three relations,
and plug and chug your way
through all of the
combinations which were
enumerated in the handout.
And I'll save ourselves a lot
of work by saying that there
are only two more
combinations.
And these are combinations of
axes at angles that have
relevance to directions
in a cube.
One of them is a twofold axis
with a threefold axis with a
threefold rotation.
Again remember these are not
equations in symmetry elements.
This is really A pi, combined
with B 2 pi over 3, combined
with C 2 pi over 3.
And the angles that fall out of
this are all crazy things
like 109 point something degrees
and they make no sense
whatsoever.
They're not nice things like
some multiples of 2 pi, 90
degrees or 120 degrees.
And they make no sense at all
until you refer them to
directions in a cube.
And this one, 2 3 3, consists
of a twofold axis coming out
of the face of the cube, a 120
degree rotation, so this is B
2 pi over 3, this is A pi.
And the other one, C2 pi over 3,
corresponds to a threefold
axis coming out of another
body diagonal.
I don't know if I want to be
gutsy enough to try to
illustrate that that
really works.
But one thing that we should do
is to let these axes go to
work on one another, and
see what comes out.
First thing we can say is that
this threefold axis--
if we extend it, it comes
out of the bottom
diagonal of the cube.
This one, if we extend it, will
come out of this diagonal
of the cube.
So there's a threefold here,
and a threefold here.
The twofold axis gives us a
threefold axis that will come
down this way.
So there's a threefold axis
here and a threefold axis
coming out here.
And then the twofold axis will
rotate this threefold axis
over to the remaining
pair of corners.
So we have created this by
looking at a twofold rotation,
combined with the threefold
axis, combined with the
rotation of another
threefold axis.
But in point of fact, if you let
the twofold axis operate
on the threefold axis coming out
of one body diagonal, you
get threefold axes
automatically
out of all body diagonals.
So this is given the
international symbol 2 3,
because if you start with one
twofold axis out of a face
normal and one threefold
axis out of--
along a body diagonal, the
twofold axis, acting on that
threefold axis gives you one
along every body diagonal.
And the threefold axis--
let me point out that a cube
standing up on its body
diagonal, with a threefold axis
coming out here and these
faces sloping down into
the blackboard.
If I have a twofold axis coming
out of one face, the
threefold axis puts a twofold
axis on this face and rotates
again 120 degrees and puts a
twofold axis on this face.
So the threefold axis relates
all twofold axes coming out
normal to the cubed face.
And they were really just two
independent axes in this
combination.
So 2 3 is the international
symbol-- one kind of twofold
axis, one kind of
threefold axis--
inclined at these crazy angles
that are in a cube.
The Schoenflies notation for
this is T, and that stands for
tetrahedron.
And let me try to convince
you that if I look at a
tetrahedron, that that is the
arrangement of pure rotation
axes in a tetrahedron.
And the way to show a
tetrahedron is to
inscribe it in a cube.
So if I connect these two faces
together and these two
faces together, that will define
for me a solid that has
four triangular faces.
Easier to recognize it when
we put it up on one face.
So this is a tetrahedron.
Schoenflies symbol is T. And I
love to get to this part of
the semester and be at this
point at the end of the hour,
because if I draw a
stereographic projection of
the twofold axes, in this
symmetry, I can take a couple
of more twofold axes and add it
to this combination which
destroys the group.
But lets me wish everybody a
happy Halloween and exit to a
stunned silence at the
end of the hour.
So this is a nice point
group for October.
There is one more and that is
the highest symmetry of all.
And this is a combination
of a rotation--
A pi over 2, a 90 degree
rotation, with a rotation B 2
pi over 3, rotation through one
third of the circle, and
the rotation C pi.
And the directions between the
axes that come out there don't
come out some multiples
of 2 pi.
Again they are crazy angles
that make no sense at all
unless you refer them
to directions
that occur in a cube.
The fourfold axis is in the
direction that corresponds to
the normal to a face.
The twofold axis corresponds
to a direction out
of one of the edges.
And the threefold axis
corresponds to a direction
that is a body diagonal.
So again this is a mess.
If we let those axes work on one
another however, we will
produce, more readily
appreciated in a stereographic
projection, fourfold axes along
the directions that
correspond to face normal.
So the cube, threefold axes
coming out of the body
diagonals and twofold axes in
between all of the fourfold
axes in directions that
correspond to the lines from
the center of the cube out
through the edges.
So this is a group which
would be called 4 3 2.
There's one kind of fourfold
axis related to all the others
by the other rotation axes
that are present.
One kind of threefold axis that
is related to all of the
other threefold axes along the
body diagonal by other
rotation axes that
are present.
And twofold axes, one kind, all
coming out of the edges.
So this is the group that, in
international tables, is
called 4 3 2.
And the Schoenflies notation,
this is called O. And that is
the general reaction when one
sees this lovely combination.
You go ooh and O is
what it's called.
But the O doesn't stand for
a gasp, it stands for an
octahedral.
This is the symmetry
of an octahedron--
rotational symmetry
of an octahedron.
So that's it.
That is the bestiary of ways
in which you can combine
crystallographic rotation axes
in space about a fixed point
of intersection.
And there are eleven of them.
There are the axes
by themselves--
1, 2, 3, 4, and 6.
There are the dihedral groups,
222, 32, 422, and 622..
And then the two cubic groups,
T and O. In the international
notation, I'm mixing
metaphors.
These are 23 and 432.
I call to your attention the
insidious similarity of the
two combinations of
axes, 32 and 23.
When the 3 comes first, this
is a group of the form n22.
When the 2 comes first, that
is the tetrahedral group.
So if you count them all up,
there are 4, 2 is 6, and 5.
There are eleven axial
combinations.
Quite a few more than the
situation in two dimensions
where we just had single
rotation axes 1, 2, 3, 4, 6.
Now we have those as in two
dimensions but the dihedral
groups and the two cubic
arrangements of axes as well.
So we don't have to stretch our
vocabulary too much more
to be all inclusive here.
OK, comments?
Takes your breath away,
doesn't it?
All right, let me indicate
the next step in outline.
What we will next do is
introduce our remaining two
symmetry operations
into the picture.
We have the eleven axial
combinations.
As I said, we can regard these
as a framework that we can
decorate with mirror planes and
or the inversion center,
which has not appeared until
this point because inversion
is inherently a three
dimensional transformation.
So what we're going to do
is to take these axial
combinations and add
another symmetry
operation to the group.
And this as--
we used the term earlier,
this is an extender.
We have something that
constitutes a group by itself
then we muck things up by adding
another operation.
Remember in all of this we are
combining operations, not
symmetry elements.
So we'll take an axial
combination and add the
reflection sigma, a reflection
operation sigma.
Or take a rotation and combine
it with the operation of
inversion as an extender.
So let's itemize the sorts of
extenders we should consider.
And the ground rules are that
the extender should leave the
arrangement of rotation
axes invariant.
Because if it doesn't, we are
going to create a rotation
operation that does not conform
to the constraints
that we used in Euler's
construction.
So for example, if we take
222, which contains the
operations A pi, B pi,
C pi and identity,
that's the group 222.
If we would add to the
arrangement 222 a mirror plane
that snaked through some
arbitrary fashion like this,
that mirror plane is going to
reproduce the twofold axis
over to here.
And that is either going to not
constitute a group because
this twofold, this twofold, and
this twofold don't conform
to Euler's construction.
Or alternatively, if we put it
in carefully at 45 degrees
with this twofold axis, we're
going to get twofold axes that
are 45 degrees apart and that's
going to change this
into a fourfold axis.
So if the addition of a mirror
plane does not leave the
arrangement of rotation axes--
rotation operations--
invariant, we're either going
to get something that's
impossible and does not
constitute a group.
Or else we're going to get
a combination of rotation
operations of higher symmetry
which we've already found
because we went through that
process of combination using
Euler's construction in
an exhaustive fashion.
So the rule then is that if we
add the reflection operation
sigma, then the arrangement of
rotation operations must be
left invariant.
OK let's look at the
single axes.
If there's an n-fold axis, the
ways we can add a reflection
operation to that axis is to
pass the reflection operation
through the axis.
And this is going to look very
much like the two dimensional
point groups of the form nmm
except that rather than having
a mirror line, imagine the
whole works as extending
upwards along the rotation
axis and space.
So this extender is called
a vertical mirror plane.
The other way we could add a
mirror plane to an n-fold
rotation axis is to put the
mirror plane in an orientation
that's perpendicular to
the rotation axis.
That didn't exist in two
dimensions because that plane
that's perpendicular
to the axis is the
plane of our paper.
And unless we wanted to have a
two-sided group that was on
both the top of the paper and
the bottom of the paper, and
we make up the rules since
it's our ball game.
And that could be a group and
these would be the two-sided
plane groups, a plane
point groups, but we
didn't do that here.
Adding the mirror plane, the
reflection operation sigma, in
a fashion that is normal to the
rotation operation, A 2 pi
over n, is another distinct
combination.
And this is called, very
descriptively a horizontal
mirror plane.
That looks like about all you
can do except for the cases
where we have more than one kind
of rotation axis present.
So let me use 422
as an example.
We could add a horizontal mirror
plane perpendicular to
the principal axis of symmetry,
and that would be
the horizontal sigma.
We could add a vertical
mirror plane.
And now there are two
ways we can do it.
We could put the mirror plane,
the operation sigma, through
the fourfold axis and in a
fashion that was perpendicular
to the twofold axis.
And we will retain the
term of vertical
sigma for that addition.
But the other thing that we
could do would be to put the
reflection operation interleaved
between the
twofold axes.
That's going to take this one
and flip it into this one,
this one flip it into this
one, flip these back and
forth, and that doesn't create
any new reflection.
And this is referred to as a
diagonal reflection plane.
Diagonal to what?
Diagonally interleaved between
the twofold axes.
And these are distinct additions
and they will lead
to different groups.
In as far as addition of
reflection operations is
concerned, that's about all
we can do that's distinct.
And notice that this is
for the groups Dn, and
tetrahedral, and octahedral
only.
The distinction here
is not defined for
just a single axis.
So there are three possible
extenders here-- a vertical
mirror plane, a horizontal
mirror plane, a diagonal
mirror plane, added to each of
the eleven arrangements of
rotation axes.
And then the final extender
that we could
add is to add inversion.
And the symbol for the inversion
operation is 1 bar.
And obviously if one point in
space is going to be left
invariant, you either add this
on a single axis, and that is
what you'd have to do for the
groups Cn, or at the point of
intersection.
And that would be the case if
more than one axis, and that's
the groups of the form n22, T,
and O. That's it.
That's the job.
So we should consider each of
these possible additions of an
extender systematically.
I don't propose to do every
single one independently.
If we do a couple, you'll
get the general idea.
And I think because I have an
honest face, and you've come
to trust me, I can just describe
the remaining results
to you and we won't grind
through every single one.
Now the enormity of what I've
proposed becomes apparent when
I say that we now are going to
have need of a number of
different--
what I call combination
theorems, that let us complete
the group multiplication
table.
And deduce, as a consequence,
which symmetry operations must
come into being because
of these additions.
So we'll want to know what
happens when you add a
vertical sigma to a rotation
operation, A 2 pi over n.
We'll want to know what
happens when you add a
horizontal sigma to a rotation
operation, A 2 pi over n.
And we're going to want to know
what happens when you add
a diagonal mirror plane, this
really is a special case of
the vertical mirror plane.
And we'll want to know what
happens when you add an
inversion center to
a rotation axis.
So let me do a few of these
and then next time we can
start off and start driving
the three dimensional
symmetries.
So let's just repeat the ones
that we've already done.
We said that if we have a
rotation operation A alpha,
and we put a reflection plane
through it, that A alpha
followed by a reflection plane
passing through it-- let me
call this sigma V-- because
this is the so-called
vertical, up orientation.
We've already seen that
in two dimensions.
This is a vertical mirror plane,
sigma prime, that is
going to be alpha over 2
away from the first.
So that is something that we've
already seen in it's
entirety in the two dimensional
point groups.
There was m sigma, there was
2mm, and that was C2V, 3m,
that's C3V, 4mm, and that was
C6V, and 6mm, and that's C4V,
and that's C6V.
So that is the result that we
obtained for two dimensions.
And you can see now the reason
for distinguishing the mirror
plane by saying it is a vertical
mirror plane because
this is in the three
dimensional sense.
It's vertical parallel to and
passing through the rotation
axis-- no longer a rotation
point but a rotation axis.
So we've got those theorems.
What happens if we take a
rotation operation, A pi, and
put a horizontal reflection
operation through it
normal to that axis?
So I'll call this sigma h,
a horizontal operation.
OK what we have to do is draw
it out once and for all.
Here's the first one, let's
say it's right-handed.
We'll rotate by A pi to get
a second one which stays
right-handed.
And then we'll reflect it down
in the horizontal mirror plane
to get a third one which
is left-handed.
And now the question is, how
is number one related to
number three?
Anybody want to hazard
a guess?
We've got to go from a
right-handed one to a
left-handed one.
But these two guys are oriented
anti-parallel to one another.
So how do we relate the first
one to the third one?
I heard somebody mumble softly
enough to remain anonymous.
Inversion.
Right.
So as we go along making these
combinations, if we had not
been bright enough to think of
the operation of inversion as
a general transformation where
the sense of all three
coordinates is changed, we
would have stumbled over
headlong right here.
Combine a rotation operation, A
pi, with a mirror reflection
that is perpendicular
to the axis.
The way you get from one to
three in one shot is by
inversion through a point that
is at the intersection between
the rotation axis and
the mirror plane.
So rotation followed by rotation
in a vertical mirror
plane that's perpendicular to
the axis is the operation of
inversion at the point
of intersection.
So again, if we had not been
clever enough to invent it or
tell you about in advance,
there it is.
When we start forming the group
multiplication table, we
would have had to have defined
this operation to describe
this relation.
AUDIENCE: Is that sigma sub h?
PROFESSOR: Ah yeah.
Let me write that, sigma h.
I thought that V didn't look
like a V, so I changed it so
it looked like a V but it
shouldn't be a V. That's a
horizontal mirror plane.
OK this is a new combination and
if we see what operations
are going to be present in the
group, we've got the two
operations of the twofold
axis, 1 and A pi.
And what we have added is
sigma h as an extender.
So 1 and A pi, this little box
here is the subgroup that we
know and love as the
twofold axis.
And then we'll write sigma h
here and now let's fill in the
group multiplication table.
Doing the identity operation
twice is identity.
followed by A pi is A pi.
Identity followed by
sigma h is sigma h.
Identity followed by A
pi, sigma h, lets me
fill in those boxes.
Do a rotation twice, that's
the identity operation.
Do a rotation of A pi and follow
that by a reflection, A
pi followed by reflection.
This is the inversion
operation.
And so I should add inversion to
my list of operations since
it's come up.
So 1 followed by inversion
is inversion.
A pi followed by inversion is
the horizontal reflection.
Horizontal reflection
followed by A pi
is the same as inversion.
Horizontal reflection followed
by horizontal reflection is
the identity operation--
brings me back to where
I started from.
And a horizontal reflection
followed by inversion is the
same as A pi.
So I'll have another object
down here to complete the
three dimensional arrangement.
And this is the group
for operations--
A pi, inversion, horizontal
reflection, and
the identity operation.
So what do we call this one?
The operation A pi plus a
horizontal reflection
operation gives rise to a group
that is a twofold axis
of its operations,
perpendicular to a mirror plane.
And this written as a fraction
means that the 2 is
perpendicular to the mirror
plane rather than being
parallel and in the plane
of the mirror plane.
So two codes for writing
symbols.
A 2 followed on the same line
by the m means that the m is
parallel to 2.
We know that when we write them
as a fraction, that will
be our way of designating that
this mirror plane is
perpendicular to
a twofold axis.
OK it's the witching hour,
4 o'clock exactly.
That's when we ought to quit,
so let's stop there.